[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
light and i'm giving you your tip for
tat the tit was your trip to key west
and it was a lot of tits yeah you're not
now i'm giving you so many tags if you
saw as many tits in big sur as i saw in
key west then
i don't know what festival that was well
let me tell you i did but they were all
on the same woman just different
instances ah okay i see where you're
going with that um so i will say there
is a little there's gonna be some
conversation about um sex
in this
seems to be something we're doing lately
if once we've you know we've busted that
hatch open yeah
and now we're just uh crawling around
out of it again and again but you know i
feel free to i think it's going to come
up in conversation yeah um okay when
telling you about my trip to big sur
with christy um at the same time that
you were in key west i was doing that it
was just the two of us shorter trip
didn't have to get on a plane
totally different vibe kind of like the
different vibes than what we're wearing
which i will get to what i'm wearing in
a little bit and also get to what you're
wearing
um but yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna talk
about that and then
i think towards the end of this
conversation
by way of recommendation i'm going to
talk about sex in a different way it's
not related to my own experience but
some things that i've learned
through a series that i watched that i
just i want to talk to you about so i'm
going to save some time for that um so
it's kind of a side a and a side b to
this conversation that i envisioned
happening um but that's a little bit of
a warning if you if you've had enough of
sex talk
from rhett and link who has then then
just who would say that go to something
else or once we start getting into that
uh you can skip
something i have a little i have a a
little sex uh update i guess you could
call it uh that i have to get into well
okay we'll go right now like errors and
omissions situation okay like last time
i teased last week's episode about
getting shot
with a wiener gun from a golf cart yeah
yeah yeah and i never told the story
because there's no story it was just i
was walking down the street
and there was a woman with a giant
penis water gun when she was just
shooting you tell me it was like a
shotgun no i'm saying it was like a
wiener i'm saying when i say giant i
mean
giant as if if it were an actual penis
uh it would be like that's a big penis
but not like a super soaker which would
be like no one's got that penis and if
they do they're like in a record book
somewhere it's just more like that's a
special record that's a big penis but
it's not it's just a it's a water gun i
don't think guinness is in the business
of measuring penis not anymore yeah
sadly they uh but they she squirted me
she squirted everyone
i mean she was just having the time of
her life with was it water yeah
i mean i didn't go on my way it didn't
go in my mouth but i didn't it didn't
smell weird
it went in your nose it just went on my
face and
like chest and oh wow
that's a bold move yeah yeah she got me
hey you can get away in that golf cart
though yeah another advantage i could
have never caught up with her of an
offer i don't know what i would have
done
grabbed her gun i had made plans to go
to big sur um
and then they were eradicated by
the pandemic so for our
um
20-year wedding anniversary which in
2020 is when we were gonna go i had it
booked i had to cancel
so i ended up going back to that same
place but since then you've been
and then i heard about the place because
stevie
recommended it
and i started looking into it it's
called glen oaks
there's
they took a motorhome not a motorhome a
motor lodge that's that's been in big
stuff for a long time and they revamped
that but you can't even really see that
i never actually saw that part of it and
then they also have cabins
like individual or
like
two cabins put together
and so you can rent out one of those
this is this is a very much a glamping
experience
it's like the best of both worlds i was
very much looking forward to it by the
time i rebooked i didn't get the cabin
that i wanted
when you're driving up through big sur
there's basically just highway one
there's nothing man and you're going
you're going up there and it's i mean
there's so many
so many screen savers of big sur that
you didn't even know like and there's
the bixby bridge which was built in 1936
this huge
beautiful arching
under arched bridge that when you drive
across it you might not appreciate how
amazing it is until you look back it's
right on the coast is that one for if
you watch uh is it big little lies
is in the intro i haven't watched that
christie watched that without me
it's good it's good especially the
bridge part oh really every episode she
only she only told me about the wiener
part
there was like there was a there was a
bars guard it was an erect wiener
walking around i think i think it was
probably a prosthetic i don't think okay
i think that's how they do it these days
so you're
when you're driving up you're you're
right on the coast and so much of the
coast is just these i know you went and
i know you talked about any of your
biscuits and i don't want to rehash
everything but i just it just bears
repeating how beautiful
maybe the most beautiful place on our
central coast of california i've never
been to the north northern coast of
california yet
and i kind of thought i was in northern
california until i looked at the map
there's a lot very much central you know
there's a whole part of north of
california the lost coast
where
it's the train is too crazy they
couldn't even get a road to like hug the
coast
that you can get there by like certain
roads yeah but our friend nick went
that's a completely different world
hardly any people up there so when
you're going i mean you're you're right
on the edge of these cliffs and you're
you can look down and just see the waves
crashing against the rugged coastline of
california there's a few places where it
turns into
very rugged beaches and there's a
handful of state parks
along
in the big sur area but when you're when
you really drive
to glen oaks and i think you went to
ventana or i can't remember what it was
called no i i i went to the
um
you can't even remember it was like the
best place i've ever stayed and it's
just completely the
post range post ranch those are like
real that's not glamping that's like
resort
stuff which is very cool and i want to
do that but it's individual cabins
though oh yeah it's not a resort it's
it's just resort prices it's exorbitant
but it uh like we stayed in a treehouse
that was just oh yeah you stayed in a
treehouse that's just an individual i do
remember this now yeah these cabins are
on the ground but when you're i i really
be i'd driven through big sur a couple
of times
and um
i began to really appreciate the
topography of at a certain point you
leave the coast and you veer
in
to
the redwoods
that are all growing in there and
there's this huge ravine huge valley and
you can't you can no longer see the
ocean and then you're kind of going down
there into the bottom and the big sur
river
comes through there is it the carmel
valley uh no
i don't i don't know that it has a name
it's it's big sur proper
like at that particular place where
these cabins are on the right side of
the road when you're going north was
where you check in and what the cabin
that christy and i ended up staying in
but the cabin i wanted and
that are the most coveted are the ones
across the street and then you walk down
to where the the river is gently flowing
through there
and there's cabins all around it and
it's nothing but redwood groves very
rustic cabins
so i want to go back and i definitely
need some reconnaissance there's an
opportunity for
like
you and jesse to come with us maybe we
can bring some other friends because
there's some other places to stay at
glen oaks that can accommodate more
people that look totally isolated and
absolutely amazing at the same place
just different parts of the same place
yeah but the cabin we stayed in was on
the other was on the other side but it
was still
an amazing glamping experience
so you got this king bed and then you've
got a little kitchenette you've got
this fireplace in the room that's very
cute nice and glampy and then they've
got
a bathroom with heated floors
oh yeah you got those heated tiles well
it gets cool up there yeah it can get
really cold it's nice to be able to walk
barefoot and then
sit down on your throne and there was a
a two-person shower
two two separate shower heads shower
pressure and heat was very great they
they really put a lot of their shower
pressure note
i mean these things really matter when
you're talking about glamping the
difference between camping and glamping
i mean shower pressure is important heat
shower pressure and i didn't know it but
heated floors in the bathroom but it's
not a motel six i mean you're gonna get
i mean if they don't get hot water i
mean
first of all motel 6 is going to give
you hot water too but you don't know
about the pressure
and you also don't know about the
mattress the mattress could have been a
little bit better the sheets could have
been a little bit better but i'm spoiled
the [ __ ] this is my room it could have
been better we got some sheets at home
that are like just t-shirt
they're so soft
and these have been like clorox to death
which makes us feel good so chris and i
are having this conversation and we're
not complaining because it's like well
you know they're clean because they're
they're hard they're a little hard
and it's they feel like they've been
bleached to death
um what i'm really trying to say is
you got the environment of camping but
it's glamorous in there oh yeah
i was very much looking forward to
staying for three nights so that i could
get two full days of just christy and i
just hanging out just being together
like there are trails that you can go on
around there but
we were like we're not gonna we're not
gonna do that this is just about us go
hiking hanging out we're not we're not
doing the hiking thing
christy had some sort of
she's and she might develop a reputation
the first time she's on this podcast one
of the first things she says is i have
diarrhea
so leading up to this trip she had diary
but she had well you didn't have to she
had gotten it under well it plays into
what happened okay
so yeah i do have to say it all right
and with her permission
but she is developing a reputation as a
diarrhea woman
uh she had gotten it under control it
kind of subsided in the two days leading
up to our trip and then we're we're
driving the five and a half hour drive
to big sur
and
we stop at uh pismo beach you remember
in 2008 for the great american road trip
we were gorgeous clam we were trying to
make the a song called the world largest
song which is basically just footage of
us in front of the world's largest
tourist trap
stuff
which we drove way out of our way
to go to pismo beach the pez museum was
also there though wasn't it
outside of san francisco in burlingame
same trip burling game and then um
matter of fact there's a there's a place
north of there called castroville that
has the world's largest artichoke you
remember going there oh yeah yeah i
remember we did our
thursday night rhett and link cast live
from the rv with very sketchy
um
internet yeah yeah from the parking lot
of the world's largest artichoke which
is basically just a like a paper mache
slash
concrete
artichoke edifice on the side of a diner
which also the world's largest clam is
also just a concrete thing yeah these
are nice welcome to pismo beach so i'm
like christy that's
i've been here
and so then it was lunchtime so we
stopped we found a highly rated place
right on the right on the beach we were
able to like watch the surf and uh we
ate this like lobster crab
roll
and then
we get back in the car
and chris is like i'm not feeling good
i think i think
some urgency is returning oh wow and i
need some more medicine so we're like
going to get some anti-diarrheal
medicine
and um
trip really started off with a bang this
is great i mean because you think about
all right we're going to get to this we
every she was okay but there was like
rumblings
right you know when you're on that road
trip and you get the rumbles
that's a little disconcerting and i mean
if yeah i'm assuming that you guys are
and you've actually talked about this
but like we're the same way it's like
when you're on vacation
and you're you're married with children
you get to the hotel room and it's first
thing you want to do is take a liquid
[ __ ] no right exactly you want to
get it on you want to break in that
cabin
you want to just bend it over and like
tell that cabin to submit where has a
cabin so involved you got to get the kit
oh yeah it's every part involve every
part of the cabinet you might have to
hold onto the wall or everything yeah
hold on hold on to those antlers
there were no antlers
i mean we do get there by the time we
got there it was
she's
like
texting the doctor's office because she
had read this thing about like how raw
onions there was a salmonella outbreak a
salmonella outbreak well like no
nationwide like 37 states and she was
pretty convinced that that's what was
happening yeah and so we get there and
yeah there's no there's no like walking
into the cabin and
getting it going it's like unless it's
a bathroom trip hey heated floors
you don't want you don't want anything
to land on this heated floors because i
guess it would start to cook okay god
you don't want to hear a sizzle from the
other room you know what i'm saying
i'm sorry guys i'm sorry
if that didn't happen and the floor
wasn't that hot it was just warm for the
record
but we finally get there and
i had
like in after we left there
and she was feeling bad and she's like
on the phone with the doctor and trying
to like troubleshoot this salmonella
stuff if that's what's been going on
with her
um
i'm like great grab that cold brew out
of the back because we're not gonna stop
for me to have the coffee that i need at
three o'clock in the afternoon and i
just drank a cold i pulled over on the
side of the road i drank a cold brew
while christy sat in the car and took an
anti-nausea pill
because then that was happening on these
like curvy pch roads and there's because
the thing i didn't know about that area
is there's not there's nothing there's a
stop at i mean there's pull-offs so you
can like look at scenery and that's the
beauty of it but there's like so this is
a little town oh there is there a
restaurant here is there a place that we
can get a cup of coffee like you'll go
very long stretches with nothing nothing
it's pristine but you don't really you
got to bring this stuff with you i
didn't want her vomiting from being car
sick as well as
everything else we established so i gave
her 20 minutes in a in sitting in the
car
while i down my cold brew
and then a couple hours later by the
time we get there i'm like man i'm
feeling bad too
i'm feeling like
super wired like i drink way too much
cold brew and i felt absolutely horrible
like my head was spinning i hadn't eaten
anything like i was also a little car
sick she was sick you guys aren't even
gonna be able to make it this is a great
start to our big sur trip you specialize
in good starts to trips though i'm
telling you man yeah the doctor
called in just for out of safety
called in um
antibiotic but we had to drive
another hour and a half north
now in the dark to carmel we had to
drive all the way to carmel yeah in
order to find the nearest um pharmacist
rite aid cvs whatever it was yeah so she
goes up there and like she gets her
anti-diarrheal stuff and she gets she
gets her prescription medications and
i'm like plopping down a couple of
enemas i'm like we've got opposite
problems here good luck
cold brew doesn't clean me out when i
travel i can't get anything going so
we're like we're like bookends on a sad
bookshelf here i mean this is your first
night this is just so you know i mean
this is probably how every vacation is
going to start 20 years from now but you
just you're just getting an early start
to it i bought four of those enemas and
i'm just going to have to carry them
with me like a gunslinger from now on
just like i got to get holsters for
these things every time i travel
oh i mean you say that i'm worried about
the fiber routine oriented like it
doesn't help my smoothie in the morning
i don't take my smoothie stuff when i
when i went on vacation i'm going to eat
like the breakfast burritos and whatnot
you know what i actually thought about
this recently
i think it's
it's legitimately good to s to if you
eat the same thing every single morning
to take a break from it on vacation
don't try to kind of thought that don't
try to bring your smoothie situation
first of all bringing your smoothie
situation on vacation would be annoying
to everyone who was with you but also i
think only one person legitimate well
your wife would be very annoyed but
legitimately i think you should take a
break from the same ingredients over and
over again every single day it will it
can be a little bit of a shock to a
system but i think it is a good practice
yeah it's not it's nothing that shoving
a
needle nose squish bottle up your rectum
yeah you just squeezing won't fix
yeah i'm sorry this is such a visceral
start to the episode yeah i don't think
it's going to get better but i didn't
talk about it it is going to talk about
glitter boobs
yeah we need a lot of those in my day
you go back there it does get better
but
first we let's promote some stuff okay
all right you got a nice looking shirt
yeah you know about uh our new it's
called adventure
psych again this is uh something that
we're doing but it's not this typical
mythical rhett and link thing it's
something that the company is doing that
kind of lives on its own it's the
uh what is it now you see it now you
don't major look that's what the slogan
is majorly you know like back in the day
psych every single thing sold on the
psych website is got a little bit of
some little curve ball going case in
point tell them about this while i hold
it in front of my face that is the
mushroom pizza shirt and the reason it
look it's actually mushroom pizza is
because if you go outside and the
sunlight hits that bad boy it will turn
into a pristine slice of mushroom pizza
but it's just mushrooms if it's inside
uh and of course this is just the
one of the psych shirts that i had never
seen anything like this we got
horizontal stripes and then we got
vertical stripes there's lots of things
over there um
dot l a dot l a psych think about that i
k
dot l-a
it's it's cool it's fun
it'll surprise you and the people that
look at you made you look
we got the stuff in her system and we
got the stuff out of my system wow and
together but it was like you know what
this tonight's just a wash let's forget
it and hopefully you we did wash it we
did watch and we just started you know
uh
start over with a clean slate in the
morning we woke up both feeling better
um
her her issues were behind her
you know you're trying
and um
it started raining
a lot ooh
like
i it wasn't
it wasn't like a hurricane or anything
but there was like but it was a lot of
rain the most rain in the shortest
period of time that northern california
has ever seen well yeah in the central
coast it was they called it like a bomb
storm like the word bomb was part of it
yeah i can't remember what it was but
yeah it was nuts and so we we got out we
got we got some coffee across the street
with our umbrellas we come back to the
room and it's i mean we got this nice
cabin
we got nothing to do but each other um
and so it was actually a it was actually
perfect
we were we were i mean
that's what we did each other
and with nowhere else to go with nowhere
else to be it's i mean a lot of times
when you go on a vacation
you know there's things you want to do
there's things you want to tick off the
checklist there's there's people that
you're going to hang out with that maybe
you're traveling with like your
your your brother and sister-in-law yeah
like without any of that and with no
kids around it was like a glorious
focus on just the two of us and it was
better than a puzzle for sure and and
let me tell you
the rain
made it an amazing experience that did
you go outside the judds have a song
rocking to the rhythm of the rain oh
yeah a judge that's a good song the
judge'll get me going anytime
we didn't play the judge but i didn't
think about it as we were rocking to the
rhythm of the rain
we didn't go outside
to to uh make love in the rain to make
love in the rain uh we stayed in this
amazing cabin and then
we were like you know what
let's just lay here and listen to the
rain i was playing some music at a
certain point that was like
um
ambient sounds that complemented the
rain but i just killed that noise
yeah i mean you know if you if you tell
your smart speaker or your sleep device
or whatever to play rain sounds
this is a legitimate top-tier way to
relax and go to sleep oh yeah it's
manufactured and comes out of your your
your smart speakers right i think for
the first time in my life i experienced
it
in its most pristine form
the night before you never heard the
rain on the roof well the night before
we noticed
that um we weren't in a redwood grove
where we were we were in actually an oak
grove
and acorns would fall and hit the roof
of our cabin and
scare the [ __ ] out of us because
uh well because of the problems we were
having that first night no because it
was just so loud
and it was you i thought someone was
like knocking on the well somebody was
walking on the roof
it was one of them
used to it but then when you add when
you replace that with rain
it was a literal sound bath
and it was an amazing experience just to
lay there
and it was so meditative
i mean to have that thing that you can
pull up on a youtube video so that you
can study or fall asleep to experience
that in its most natural form
i yeah i had never experienced a
legitimate
rain on a hot serenity
it was i mean it was a it was a
highlight of my life
especially especially
sexing in the rain now that was amazing
uh i i know how you tend to get
enthusiastic about things like this
um because i wa i make a decision to
drink in life in those moments and say
you know what it doesn't get any better
than this other things are going to be
and this is me talking well no that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
i'm trying to figure out it doesn't get
any better than this things have gotten
this good but nothing is going to get
better than this
yeah you make a decision to do it but
you also make a decision to say that
you're doing it and to try to get
everybody else to do it too so i'm just
saying yeah cause christie like yeah i'm
oh she was she she was she was with
she's shaking her head at you she was
she was with me i mean it was it was
really magical i think she you know
it's she's taking up the reins too it's
i mean no one wants to be like hey
listen
you need to just
i get it this is awesome
but i don't need you to tell me that
it's awesome i do understand that and i
wasn't doing it forever i mean we i we
literally just lay there
and listen to the rain
i don't want to ever forget it
uh
definitely over an hour
and this is after like
many hours of intense lovemaking
oh man
give me a break no it wasn't many hours
but it when you don't have anything else
to do besides each other you can stretch
everything out and it's nice to get
reacquainted with that and say hey
remember on our honeymoon when we did it
so much that we could we were walking
like cowboys
let's see if we can match that yeah
let's see if we can have
um
multiple
sessions yeah
but you find yourself saying hey let's
actually you know what let's just listen
to the rain for an hour it might take me
that long to uh
to re-up that well after that first
session the perspective changes the rain
cleared up by mid-afternoon and we went
to uh we went back to the place that you
guys had recommended that we have been
before called
nepenthe or it's right on the coast yeah
it's like there's a bookstore and a
restaurant and you sit on the back of
the restaurant and you over you can you
you just look at beautiful view look at
the ocean it's absolutely amazing we saw
an amazing sunset
and um we're like talking to the waiter
like making friends
laughing louder than anybody else there
you know again like i said last episode
um it's just like just feeling in the
zone feeling like oh look we're we're
having the most fun we're connecting
we're like it feels like we're on our
honeymoon again
and uh we're watching this beautiful
sunset and
look over at christy's purse
and it had been
up on the
we were sitting at a bar so we could
both sit shoulder to shoulder and watch
the sunset like that was the best seat
in the house
and up on the up on that bar
her bag was like open
and it turns out something was spilling
out of it and every time that anyone
walked by or the person sitting right
beside christy on the other side could
definitely see
that she had a huge box of
anti-diarrheal medications just out
there in front of everybody
and uh christie's like like putting it
away after at the end of our whole meal
after being there for like two hours and
we're like talking to the guy about it
he's like yeah i saw that but i didn't
want to say anything
so it's even though i don't know it just
wouldn't leave us like it was this the
diarrhea was a specter well yeah we need
to be ready there we ate that we had uh
just a coffee
at that place it's a cool spot and uh
it's a very
wild
bird
that was very aggressively eating
people's food oh there wasn't one off of
their table
i ate a chicken sandwich yeah
um next day
we got up
and there was no rain in the forecast
for that day so i'm like all right
today's the day that we're going to go
down by the river
and again no hiking
we're going to go in like full
meditative retreat mode
they take these adirondack chairs are
you familiar um yeah i believe so well
describe it adirondack chair to me is
one of those like high-backed made out
of wood yeah he just kind of leans back
a little bit yeah and you're kind of low
to the ground
they had taken pairs of those and put
them in the big sur river
because the river is basically just a
really wide stream and there's lots of
places where you can just sit on the
rocks
so we just went down there and sat for a
while and just
didn't feed in the water
uh too cold for that
i was like i'm gonna get totally ready
for this i'm gonna put on my new
sweatshirt i don't know if you've
noticed this this is the moment this is
the moment you explain yourself i
ordered this thing off an instagram ad
uh shout out to my friend todd snyder
teaming up with l.l bean
and it makes quite a statement i'm like
i think this is um
how do you say ironic
but not really
it kind of says
i
don't really go camping but i like the
idea of camping yes
and
this isn't
th i think this is maine
you know you got some ducks flying you
got some you got some fall foliage going
all the way down the sleeves on this
thing yeah that's quite a print i think
it's not easy to do i did get a
compliment or two
for it
what what do they say i think it was
something like sweatshirt what did he
say he was we were in one of these like
little you'll find a little bookstore
yeah on the edge of this yeah like with
some like philosophical
stuff people doing a lot of
introspection
yeah i think he said something like that
sweatshirt
is hot
not hot maybe he was like fire i don't
think he said no cap i can't remember
but who was this guy it was just a dude
who seemed cool how old he was a little
younger than me
so okay i think it it worked for him it
definitely worked for me
and i got the photos to prove it so here
i am sitting in the big sur river in an
adirondack chair wearing my turtleneck
sweatshirt
scene
um they were on the rocks it was just
too it was a little bit too cold but
okay you put your feet in it's not like
in the water it's it's like on a rock
right right right okay right so it was
just another day of
nothing
and and kind of looking like walking
around the grounds of this place going
back to the room
having another love making session
it's just not you know it's just like
you set your parameters small and then
it's
just a lot of
you know what i'm going to be naked
i'm going to be naked
literally there's something about it
i was like i'm going to be naked in this
cabin oh yeah for a long time and
there's something about big sur that
does that to you because
when we were up there we had in the tree
house we had the fire
and then i was just like why do
clothes
why
yes and and i was and that's why when
you're talking about glitter boots and
stuff is like i'm actually i was much
more open to that story and like putting
a tube sock on my on my pants it's one
thing to be in a cabin another thing to
be on duval street in key west i know
but maybe it's a slippery slope
not for me
my feet are firmly gripping the i love
being naked
and i i realized that there's a freedom
in that that like the something we were
watching that i'll talk to about talk to
you about
kind of informed this mindset
so again i'll get to that but the
experience was
you know what i'm this is my body these
are our bodies and we're just we're into
each other and we're not into clothes
unless you need them and we bought our
own blanket because we brought our
favorite blanket
so i mean a little blanket is nice but
like there's just something magical
about
being together
and just saying you know what
we need not clothing
it just felt edifying it felt like okay
i'm comfortable i'm accepted we know
each other we can
we can do this it's cause it's not the
type of thing that you normally do
i mean i don't walk around my house and
naked well no i mean you got
children right but i do anticipate now
first of all i definitely do too i i i
well i do walk around my house naked
if like if i am naked and i need to get
something from downstairs
there are and i'm like i don't want to
put on anything i'm going to go down and
get i got you know i got two boys and
it's just
but it isn't a regular thing but i do
anticipate when the kids move out that
it will become a normal thing i like
that idea for me
in my house i mean why not and then
there's a pool and you i mean i'll jump
into that pool naked
at the right time yeah if the right
people aren't looking out the windows or
the neighbors aren't home yeah there's a
couple of vantage points from other
yards i think in my pool but um
it was ever it was everything i hoped it
would be it's it's not that there's that
much to report it's just and i think
that's the point is that
i had this idea and again
i'll have ideas of how i want things to
go and
but
it was
and it started off really rough and i
didn't let it get to me
and even even in day two when like
things cleared up and i'm wearing the
sweatshirt and we're out in the river or
we're back just being in our nakedness
did everything go exactly how i had
written in the novel in my mind of
course not
and christy knows this about me and so
there's dif there's certain points where
she can see the eyebrows crinkle a
little bit or she can hear a little
intonation is something i'm saying and
she can graciously redirect my
me to let go of my expectations and
enjoy
what we have
and what we're doing but if and so that
happened
uh at a couple of points
but overall it was just such a beautiful
experience of us just being together
with very little agenda
and very little clothes did you it was
something i noticed
uh
that is unusual and like we know i noted
it and jesse noted it
was how quickly i
adjusted to vacation which is
uh not an easy thing for me to do now we
worked
you know
we don't typically travel in october
unless it's for work and so putting
something in the middle of october which
just the way that the year is stacked it
tends to be our busiest time
and
what happens when we travel is it isn't
like anything we do less it's just we do
more and it gets pushed on either side
of the trip and it's just the schedule
gets really packed on each side of the
trip and we were working
when i got home on the wednesday night
before leaving on a thursday morning
i was so
worn out
and
there's so many things kind of going on
in my mind and things that i could latch
onto and worry about at any given time
but something like when i got off the
plane i kind of made this decision i was
like i'm not going to worry about
anything work related i'm not going to
think about the stuff that i could be
doing and also i'm not going to obsess
about all the seven different things
that i could see in key west i've got
these people here who know the place
they've made reservation reservations
i'm just going to be along for the ride
and actually had one of the better times
that i've ever had because i wasn't in
charge well i wasn't in charge but all
but also it was like
there's certain things that i didn't see
i didn't go into ernest hemingway's
house which i could have done right as
an example it's like some oh everybody
says good take the tour we didn't go and
then i was like hey leave something to
do the next time you come whatever don't
who cares just it i i it's very hard for
me to be in the moment and for some
reason because we were working so hard
right up until that moment
i found myself being able to do that
more than i ever have and i was like am
i reaching an age where i can do it is
that was that what's happening it's
crazy i was thinking the same things on
our drive back the next day i told
christy i was like you know what for the
past two days
i don't think i thought about work
and it was i mean we had internet in the
room when you're walking around and
outside of your cabin we didn't have any
service so that helps
um
but yeah i mean it felt like one of the
because usually you go for a week-long
vacation and it takes half the time to
get to the point where you're no longer
thinking about the stuff
and then
as you're starting as it creeps back to
when you're coming back into the real
world you start thinking about it again
you start thinking about the fact that
the vacation is over right so then
they're like man we're gonna go home
there might be one day of a sweet spot
in the middle where you didn't think of
anything
but yeah i actually noticed i haven't
thought about work
the past two days i gave myself
permission to do that and i think i
needed it enough and i you know
i wanted to provide
focus on the right things
and it was it was just
yeah it's kind of what you want a
vacation to be
even though it was only two full days
for us and a travel day on either side
that even being in the car was nice you
know because it's such a scenic drive
and everything
um so yeah i mean i definitely
think that was my takeaway is that
with this particular trip you got the
the beauty of the ocean the cliffs the
red woods and it just br
i would put it on that for me that it
brought me into this meditative state
um
and uh apparently a
a good floridian island will do the same
thing if you're in the right
circumstances
it's nice to be it's nice that we're
both it may have that experience it may
be i it could just be
we haven't traveled in a while yeah uh
because i just i noted it i was like man
i like real i just did quickly how do i
make sure i do this next time i know for
real i mean it's not easy but but
there's there's one house that has like
it's called a bridge house you have to
walk across the suspension bridge across
the big sur river and then there's it
has two
uh
bedrooms and then a
a kitchen and a nice living room area
and
there's a there's a barrel sauna outside
right next to the river with a picnic
table and bocce ball and like these
amazing
rings goodness of i didn't rent that it
was this is the place i want us to go
back to
and then if we bring other friends
there's like
um
they retro
they they created these standalone
bedrooms
that are like super nice that like you
could you bring some other people it's
like i definitely want to go back and do
that in october that's the perfect time
you get that rain but then it goes away
and there's not all the fog coming off
of we got lucky we went not a lot of
which was usually super foggy and just
we got lucky but the thing that christy
and i watched
in our downtime
um when we just couldn't go at each
other anymore
was
uh this
goop series on netflix called sex loving
goop i've seen the trailer so
um of course goop is this is the gwyneth
paltrow
it's not just wellness it's it's all
types of stuff and it's what just
gwyneth stuff years ago she was she got
flack for like saying oh put this egg in
your vagina for a long time and jade egg
the jade egg and she said you named your
dog after it she got a lot of pushback
for stuff like that
uh and she did a mini series uh
a goop series on netflix like a year ago
that was a bunch of like i don't know
you spend a lot of money on something
that's very questionable it seems like
that's kind of the reputation with
what she's putting out into the world
but this new series
um
she's not she she's not really the
center of it
and we watched the whole thing while we
were there and that's my recommendation
but i wanted to talk through some of
this stuff with you because oh it's
basically
um
a
episodic series docu series on sexual
healing
uh of real life couples paired with a
sexologist mm-hmm is
wanted to jump in here and um give a
clarification this is after recording
everything that you're currently
listening to we had a discussion about
goop in light of the fact that
a lot of controversy came to light
after we recorded
me talking about that goop series and
the controversy
i mean controversy is nothing new to
goop but i just wanted to say
there's certain
uh therapeutic practices that are
platformed in the series that people are
pointing out are illegal in most states
highly questionable
the one that i know about specifically
is not one that
uh
i'm telling you about in this episode
right but in general i just wanted to
say
i'm not endorsing any of these practices
i don't know enough to do that and i
hope you know enough to like use your
own judgment i'm basically just saying
this is a fascinating show to watch
and be exposed to and it just got me
thinking about some things that i'm not
saying are entirely right
or even entirely legal because
i don't know
so i'm just putting that out there and
framing this whole conversation
with caution that you need to be
responsible for yourself and
how you apply
any of the stuff from that series if at
all no endorsements and i'll add that um
if you didn't already know goop is not
doesn't necessarily have the reputation
for being uh the most
reliable or evidence-based source of
uh lifestyle and health advice
um you know the there's there's a number
of things that have come up in the past
few years but we are entertained by the
way that they go about things
uh so again whatever link said i agree
with this is not an endorsement we were
entertained by this thing but we because
of this reason whatever i said you
weren't listening to us no okay he
agrees with us but we just want we
endorse his mind
we know how the internet is and we know
that when you talk about something
that's controversial people assume that
it's an endorsement we wanted to confirm
that it is not an endorsement
now let's go back to it
and so these are real people who like
from all walks of life you got old
people you got a lesbian couple you've
got um people dealing with
challenges in being intimate or
like being they're being a mismatch in
what what drives them and then so it's
kind of like seeing the therapeutic
techniques
um that they're experiencing first hand
and sometimes with multiple hands
involved as i'll get to
and it gets wild
and really out there in a couple of key
places one that i'll tell you about but
i really enjoyed
the heart behind this thing i mean
christy recommended it
and said hey let's watch this thing and
i thought okay this will be fun this
this might make us horny
that's what i was thinking but then it
was it was actually very
eye-opening and educational some people
might describe parts of it as
pornographic and it might make you
uncomfortable but if you've been through
sex timber i think you're
you'd probably be ready to check this
thing out
um but i give it to these couples who
are like totally
normal people with normal problems in
their
relationships and they're like super
vulnerable and the stuff that they were
asked to do
on camera but one of the things that one
of these sexologists talked about was
an erotic blueprint test
that determines the way in which you
best receive pleasure
and this is something that like
i i was able to connect a few dots with
this but i had a language for sex
yeah so the um
the different erotic blueprints are
energetic sensual sexual kinky or
shapeshifter so energetic means you're
aroused by anticipation and yearning
so it's like
what's
it's not what is happening is what's
about to happen like poorly am i ready
for this and it's um
it's it's foreplay but then sometimes it
goes into more of this like
woo energy thing which i'll talk about
second one
is
sensual
where so you're turned on when all the
senses are ignited
remember how many there are five or six
like the vaginas in a candle candle
yes
sight smell
touch
what are the other ones rubbing
insertion sound
sounds
taste the next one is sexual which is
excited by nudity and
or other traditional sexual
characteristics a lot of this is
associated with the the sexy bits
you know okay the parts that you're
supposed to cover up on like the angles
to be decent angles ankles
i'm really into ankles
no i'm talking about the twigs the
berries yeah yeah yeah
the
tunnel of love the nappy dugout
yeah as um ice cube called it and
something
um
so and that's the one that you you know
you tend to think about like okay when
sexual stuff is what i'm is is at play
when you're activated sexually yep but
only that stuff um kinky
aroused by taboo
and then shapeshifter is just all of the
above yeah so christian i mean it
doesn't it's not a teaching series it's
more like they're sharing this with the
people in order so that this one
particular couple could understand
how they would
how to kind of like a love language
thing how do they like meet each other's
expectations and like she's putting one
of them on a table and then it's like
okay based on your survey you're kinky
and she's like oh i am and then he like
gets out she gives the sexologist gives
her partner a paddle and he like and
he's like i'm not kinky he's just a high
he was uh i mean his eyebrows are going
up all the time
as he's like trying to like figure out
how hard does she like to be
spanked with this paddle right and then
there's like the whips
and like the the thing like the big
thing with the chains hanging from it
and it's like well you don't whip the
person with this you just slowly
drape it on them and and drape it on her
crotch and then you have the weight of
these chains just the feeling of chains
is um
i think she was like
sensual and kinky if i remember
correctly
but then
uh they switch up and they put him on
the table and i'm a golfer
and
he wasn't he wasn't like that but like i
mean they gave him like wolverine claws
to like start scratching down her body
and like a very
uh
no blood was drawn right yeah it was
very approachable it made kinky
approaching you're a big wolverine fan
it did make me think that i was a
shape-shifter because no matter what i
saw
i wanted to try i could try that
um but that feels like the page i'm on
so far yeah they put him on the table
and
and then the sexologist is like you are
an energetic
and then
he started like talking about like put
your hands over the person do you feel
the energy and i'm like okay here we go
i don't believe in any of this [ __ ]
but then they started
he started being touched in a way
that
the dude had what
is called an energetic orgasm he came in
his pants without being touched he had a
f i don't know if he
ejaculated in his britches well that's
an orgasm but his whole body was shaking
he was like he started crying
it was
wild it really was what and i didn't
know this was a thing
and then they're like okay yeah this is
this is what you are and this is what
happened though just hand placement
without touching
honestly i can't remember all the
specifics of what they did to him
maybe it was because nothing was
vibrating like under the table that we
couldn't see
nothing that i saw uh you'll have to
watch it for yourself if you want to
really
i can't remember the specifics of what
they did it was more about the result
and him knowing that this was kind of
this was his sexual
his
his sexual love language his erotic
blueprint
but then the sexologist is like now you
get off now let me show you where you
can go with this basically since this is
this is
a way that you're able to get off and
you guys can learn that from each other
go stand next to a transformer just no
just sit here and watch me and then the
sexologist lays down on the table fully
clothed
and she's like i'd like to introduce you
to my business and life partner
and this
this middle-aged bald dude comes out and
he looks like a
i mean he's got like a golf shirt on i
don't remember what he had on my name i
remember that i don't remember like
raymond or something like that it was un
but he looked like a like an evil bond
villain he had a i wouldn't say that his
head was bulbous but it was bald and all
of his facial features were kind of
concentrated on the lower half of his
face that's better that way so it's kind
of it was kind of like you can see smell
and taste things that are all at the
same time and he had a smirk but he
didn't really talk
and then all of a sudden he starts
putting his hands over his partner and
he never ever touched her like david
copperfield and it was kind of like this
super villain magician type thing and he
had one hand
it was kind of you know when um
the lord of the rings when sauron kind
of like put his
hand over the pellentier and like it
like his hand was like it was kind of
like he was drawing
a connection with sauron out of that
crystal ball and like his fingernails
and his hand was like getting like
twiggy
it was like it was like weird and like
that happened on netflix like this dude
well what he did was he did that with
his hand above her head
and then she got her eyes closed kind of
over her crotch
and he looked like he was pulling on
strings like a freaking puppeteer
and then she
is just going crazy
like she is she is undulating having a
full body orgasm
all over this table
all over the table like she was writhing
all over the table moaning and and
arching her back and putting her knees
in the air and throwing her legs all
over the place and
he was never touching her but doing this
thing that
from my perspective
it was a it was an elaborate performance
well
can i and i think so having not seen it
it was wild i didn't really buy it but
the other guy totally bought well here's
the thing
you ever um
you know like
this hasn't happened to me recently but
well i've done it with my kids where
you're like you're doing it with your
kids you know you're tickling your kids
and then you've got them you've got them
held down and then you get really close
to tickle them and they laugh and
because it's the anticipation of getting
tickled like i think and they would call
that an energetic response i think that
it is
like i mean listen i don't know i i
don't claim to know things about
metaphysical things anymore it's that's
kind of where i'm at but
the idea that he there's literally like
some energy field that he's kind of
running through her vagina and then
coming out on top of her head and like
literally like what was the guy in
pinocchio
he's like
his woman i don't think that's what's
happening but like the the idea is so
powerful right and that her mind is
literally able to activate
a sexual response like i totally believe
that that could happen i i agree with
that and there was no denying that this
guy who was in
who was in tears and like
took him hours to recover from what
happened to him on the table
is um it just seemed like it was a very
extreme demonstration
that might i don't know if the waters
got kind of muddied for me and you
expect a little bit of that from from a
goop thing yeah it's gonna be it's not a
lot a little goopy you gotta get goopy
there was a couple other goopy moments
too um
that
those are great reasons to watch and
just like
just to
just for your jaw to drop
but again
i have to recommend it because the way
that these couples were so vulnerable
and the sexual component to their
relationship and one of the things that
clicked early on was they said
one of the
sexperts
that you know it's a
lovemaking is a
is a skill
it's like a craft
and it was really cool to for us to be
watching it and then to have all of this
time where it's like okay we can we
don't have anywhere to be or anything
else to do it's just raining and so we
can like actually embrace this as
something that we're there's still a lot
to learn
about our own bodies and about each
other's bodies and i never i've never
heard of these classifications you know
had you energetic sensual sexual kinky
shapeshifter not and not no not broke
broken down like that right and knowing
that there might be a mismatch to like
um
the the woman
in in that
in that couple was like am i gonna have
an orgasm at any point in my life am i
gonna
she said am i gonna have an orgasm
before i have a baby because i think
they were they were thinking about
trying to have kids but like
she kind of wanted to check that box you
know and as she
as she should
um
but it
i was blown away by the just the
vulnerability and just how because i
haven't read a lot of those
books which i'm sure you could get some
of this stuff from it was a it was a
cool introduction to it and it had some
sensational parts that really popped
that made it a lot of fun to watch we're
going to bring uh sexologists in for sex
september 2022 maybe
right i mean i mean i laid out i
couldn't fit on this table right here i
mean would you lay down i had to bring
in a different table for a netflix my
head would go out that side my feet
would be out this side like i mean
a lot of these people they would be like
i'm
i'm going to do this on netflix like
they would say that well they're getting
paid i mean probably a pretty
significant significant amount
you know i was very cool what what i
will say it's interesting we had very
different trips but there are parallels
even in this area
and i think that this is again this is
typical of vacations for
for
for me and jesse and you and christy as
you've described
but you know i actually wasn't with
jessie
the entire week leading up because she
went to north carolina
at the beginning of the week
and was kind of hanging out with her
family there and then
went down to the keys on wednesday so
i'm flying down on thursday night so we
haven't seen each other for like four
days oh that's a good technique send her
early
well she sent herself
had some business to take care of in
north carolina
and um
you know like
the i got in at like 6 30. so
she is they're all ready to go out
for dinner right
and so like uh
chris pix picks me up but jessie's there
and like she like steps out of the car
and she's like in her little black dress
and her
all made up in her heels and she didn't
drive up on a bike no she did not and uh
i'm like okay well what time is dinner
you know i'm saying because we got we
have a little bit of time let's go to
the hotel room
and i mean it was it was it was very
intense
and i like that's a great way to start
meet on the vacation that no don't i'm
not saying we had sex
at the airport i'm saying we waited till
we got back to the hotel room
and then
there's always this thing
kind of what you were getting at before
which is like
sometimes in in a in a relationship if
there's like pre-dinner sex
sometimes you
you're less motivated after dinner right
you're kind of like um
well no we followed up dinner and then
proceeded to i mean it was reset you hit
a reset then it was like it became a
thing it was like this is going to
happen multiple times a day the whole
time that we're together
and of course the whole dynamic that we
talked about during sex timber where
you have to kind of get yourself into a
place where you're willing to
not care about people hearing you and
people in the room next to you hearing
you and that kind of thing
uh but we got there very quickly and
kind of maintained that and we didn't
really talk we didn't talk about it we
talked about how we were having a really
great time and now we were really
connecting and we enjoyed being with
each other and
uh
but yeah it was a really
uh
we were very in sync
much more than when we were kayaking i
mean i thought about trying to slip off
and have sex on the kayak considering
how well things were going maybe that
would have
uh
you know solved some problems but no
that didn't happen but yeah it was it
was a really good time
for that kind of connection probably but
maybe i mean i haven't done the
puppeteer thing so maybe i got to watch
this thing that's what i'm telling you
man
so that's my recommendation actually for
this one
is the goop
sex love and goop and you know
i've told you what you're signing up for
if you if so if you're not into that you
shouldn't watch it and it's like yeah
you're gonna there's some eye rolling
parts to it but it's like i'll just take
it with a grain of salt
you don't have to agree with everything
in order to get something out of it
well you know that that's one of the
one of the things i most enjoy about
uh sort of my post
evangelical life yeah is a there as an
evangelical christian there was for me
there was always this i was very in a
very defensive and protective mode with
every single thing that i enjoyed every
single thing that i watched every single
conversation that i was in you're kind
of always on guard for is this enough
first of all you're with people is this
an opportunity to witness to them but
then when you're watching something
you're trying to make sure that it's
going through the proper grid and you're
classifying these people as this isn't
good this is not christ-like this is not
a christian this is not biblical you're
either in or you're out so every yeah
everything was
assessing that and there's an
interesting thing with when i don't know
is it is it right or wrong are you in
are you out and that grid doesn't exist
anymore
so now it's kind of like huh okay that
but the interesting thing is it isn't
like every anything goes and
everything's good but it's kind of like
i can watch something and just take it
in and be like this doesn't have to
change the way i feel about think about
this but it might you know and
again i don't believe the energy stuff i
mean it could be true but i don't know
there's a way to prove it i haven't
experienced it but like being able to
watch something like that and be like
this is entertaining slash informative
maybe it'll spark something for us and i
don't have to have this
complex informed opinion about why it's
worldly
that's one of the best things about my
life at this point that just makes i
just it's a lot there's a lot less
emotional energy put in like putting
things in boxes and i i think that
you know since
this is kind of like a
a sex addendum to
sex timber you know weeks later um
i do think there are ripple effects in
me and christie's relationship from sex
timber it's like really getting in that
head space where you're like you're
thinking about it
well you and i are thinking about it and
talking about it and then christy and i
are the four of us did in that one
episode and then it
um
i she's grateful i think she's she's
glad that she was on the show because
it's part is one of the factors that led
to us
having intentional intimacy
and giving and giving attention to that
our sex lives
and saying okay that will actually be
part of the mission for this trip for us
so i'm i look i'm already looking back
on sex timber and being very very
grateful for it and i think um
and there's an you know christie's
christie's reading a book called come as
you are which i would also recommend
that book
and
um so it's you know the wave has
crescendoed but it's like it's still is
still moving us along in terms of
giving attention to it and also being
realizing that now that we've talked
about it
it's
it's less and less weird every time we
bring it up
like she's the one that's like and she
put in our text there she's like look at
this goop series i'm gonna watch this
you guys should watch this too you know
it's like i don't i think she could have
done that before but maybe she wouldn't
have maybe she wouldn't have identified
that it's like so we
i think we are realizing the benefits of
having those conversations and kind of
bringing it to the surface now
all that being said
well
if i had to predict
on the on the back side of our big sur
trip is it this now we're having so much
more sex it's like no i can already tell
that it's like
man that was that was great and that was
very concentrated and now we're kind of
getting back to our our normal lives and
our normal rhythm and our normal uh
uh
frequency is the word i'm looking for
you know
of
of being intimate
but again because it's we talk about it
differently now we talk about it more
often we talk about it more even more
openly and so i think
it was a good thing i'm glad we did it
i'm glad we're still doing it keep doing
it
i i do think that that is um
you know we talked about this during sex
timber but i think it is worth repeating
is just the idea that
just like anything
that communication and
talking about something
leads to
enhancements and progression
in that particular area
of your relationship and that might be
your sexual relationship
um
because i do think there is a
there's a tendency for i mean i'm not a
very routine oriented person but that
doesn't really that doesn't really
matter
because
there is a tendency you kind of get into
things that are comfortable
and and i'm just talking about in
relationships in general right if
there's like yeah okay well this thing
about you annoys me
or i feel hurt in this way
but i just don't know how to talk about
it i don't know how to
bring it up and so
years will pass
and we don't really make like we just
accept
that this is the status quo
and i don't know my impression
is that there are there's there's many
there's many couples and relationships
where there's issues like that that
relate to their sexual lives where
it's like hey
hey we looked up and 15 years had passed
and we haven't had
a meaningful sexual connection not
because we don't want to but because
there's something maybe it's we're on a
different page when it comes to the
stuff the way that it was broken down or
whatever and that's the thing that i
loved about that series is that these
were not people that was like we're
celebrating how great their sex lives
are it's like these are people with
real
challenges and deeply rooted in certain
case studies
issues that go to the core of who they
are as individuals and what they're
bringing to the relationship and they
put all that out there and i think it's
you know i'm extremely grateful for
uh
the experiences that chris and i have
and i know you are with you ingested
like things are going so well and that
was one of the concerns that i had with
sex timber was like
i just feel like we we celebrate how
much we have to be thankful for and that
we can build on
knowing that there's so many people who
like as you're getting at right now it's
like they're they're in a different
place because of different reasons that
aren't their fault
necessarily or most likely
and it's
and it
it takes it takes work and sometimes
help to get through that and it's and so
i applaud those people and i think
they're those are great examples to kind
of round out something that we're not
able to talk about when it's well i mean
it's just the
the intention
the decision to go on that show which he
knows what the casting process is or
whatever
but there you know you don't have to go
on a netflix show
but it might take hey like
let's actually go see a sex therapist as
a couple
like oh this is oh this is uncomfortable
but yeah
what about the next 10 years
yeah it's just it's anything when you
need to talk to somebody about anything
that breaking through that initial
conversation
it's just again it's just so much easier
to not have it it's just so much easier
to just have the neck tomorrow be just
like today yeah back burner it or no
burner it but i mean
so when i was talking about like
enjoying being naked
and like embracing that it was informed
by
messages in that show and just saying
you know what i so i got to a point
where christy and i was like
i think i want to start an only fans
okay all right it's like it can be both
of us you can be in charge of the camera
if you don't want to do it you can be in
charge of the camera and my face doesn't
have to be on it
i don't know i could be in a not i want
to i could do an anonymous thing i think
i i think i could be an exhibitionist
hmm okay
i doubt this is gonna actually happen so
does she
but there are couples uh
you know there's so much independent
porn right now
and there are couples that for whatever
reason
because of whatever else they do or just
their own prerogative they don't show
their faces
um
you know you're gonna have the tattoo
could be a problem i mean you have your
wife's name as i do
my wife's name on our asses so you have
to put something over that and then
you've got the
the elvish
yeah tattoo that you have to do
something with that a lot of band-aid
and you can't say anything
you know you don't want to make any
noises
you can yeah use a french accent you're
good at that and uh i mean it's a
natural extension of what we do right
emphasis on the extension
[Laughter]
no i i don't think i will ever do it i'm
just i'm i was messing with her
tongue-in-cheek
but um
i don't know
you got people now you got people who
are legitimately gonna think that you
might start an only fan but you know
that's a good one that's a good place to
have fun don't go searching it's a good
place to i haven't perused only fans i
don't know uh you know what the
thumbnails show but uh don't peruse it
on my account trying to find me because
you won't
um and it'll be really easy because i'll
be the guy wearing this sweatshirt and
nothing else oh gosh
yeah
focus on the ducks
well hopefully you learned a lot
this week uh and last week as we ended
up just let's do it in sex timber all
over again
um
hashtag your biscuits tell us what type
of sexual no don't type
we don't wanna know no no wait listen
save it because i i mean i have every
intention of doing sex temper again but
i don't i don't know how it's going to
change we kind of already told the
stories i think i think we might have to
bring in some experts i don't know man i
don't know it's too early to say but
you know i really like to do it again
i'll i'll have learned a lot from my
only fans experience uh to discuss yeah
right
talk at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best